les derniers ont plié leurs tentes ce matin. 2000
teufeurs se sont donnés rendez vous ce weekend à
yzeures-sur-creuse pour une free party en plein
champs. La préfecture avait pourtant pris les
devants en prenant 2 arrêtés d'interdiction en
vain donc. Jusqu'à 120 gendarmes mais aussi des
secours ont dû être déployés. Romain Delville
était sur place. Rejoindre une free party,
c'est toute une aventure. Avec les gendarmes
qui bloquent l'accès aux routes il faut marcher
4 km à travers champs, passer une forêt pour
accéder au taillis de Cirande, le lieu de RDV
sur la commune d'Yzeures-sur-Creuse. Pour ce
groupe de jeunes chauffeurs c'est une sorte
de rituel obligé : c'est plus joyeux d'accéder à
une genre de soirée où on a traversé une colline,
une forêt, ou en soit on sait même pas où on
va et c'est cool en vrai, moi j'aime bien. Sur
place les dj se relaient avec leurs différents
styles du mélodique au hardcore pur et dur.
Un vent de liberté souffle sur la plaine.
Lena des deux-sèvres partage le moment
avec sa mère : les teufs ça existe depuis hyper
longtemps, c'est depuis les années quatre-vingt,
c'est hyper vieux les teufs, la techno et tout ça.
Du coup ouais y'a des gens de tout âge qui vient,
mois je viens avec ma mère... et c'est super
cool enfin je veux dire... ouais y'a vraiment
des gens de tous les âges pour le coup donc oui
c'est intergénérationnel carrément. Et monter
une fête illégale car non déclarée c'est pour
beaucoup un acte politique : prendre possession
d'un champ sans rien demander, installez les
murs du son, c'est créer un espace autogéré
alternatif et hors du système légal. De la
même manière que le système d'aujourd'hui
nous impose certaines choses et ben nous on leur
impose un peu nos soirées et je trouve que c'est
un bon moyen de répondre à la répression à
tout ça. Changement d'ambiance au poste de
commandement installé dans la salle des fêtes
d'Yzeures-sur-Creuse : le maire de la commune,
des pompiers, des gendarmes en uniforme,
des forces de l'ordre en civil vérifient
en liaison avec les collègues sur place que la
situation est sous contrôle. Il y a évidemment
la coordination de l'ensemble des moyens, le fait
de bloquer les accès routiers pour empêcher qu'un
nombre plus important de manifestants enfin de
participants se rendre sur les lieux et ainsi en
faisant croître l'ampleur de l'événement augmente
les risques susceptibles de se matérialiser. Le
maire a annoncé qu'il allait porter plainte
pour dégradation des sentiers communaux mais
dans une fête où par définition personne n'est
organisateur officiel cela ne va pas être facile
de trouver des responsables. Voilà justement
trois plaintes vont être déposées celle de la
commune donc mais aussi de l'exploitant
agricole et du propriétaire du terrain,
enfin sur twitter ce coup de gueule du patron des
pompiers d'Indre et Loire Yvon Paturel dénonce
le détournement des moyens de secours de leurs
missions régaliennes pour un événement illégal